[Musica]
abbiamo sentito un po di storie di
successo io vi parlo un po di fallimenti
invece cinque mesi fa una rivista di
viaggi americana conquistavo
collaborando mi commissione un articolo
su come viaggiare lungo la via della
seta senza prendere questa breve guida
neanche dopo approfondita spiegava come
arrivare da cia anni in cina a istanbul
in turchia passando attraverso l'asia
centrale un viaggio che avevo fatto
qualche anno fa per me è una piccola
soddisfazione riuscire a parlare di dei
posti e degli argomenti che avevo cuore
su una rivista internazionale nella mia
seconda lingua
però considerando che per essere in
grado di pubblicare questo è il tipo che
si è promesso nove anni il 60 dollari
che mi davano non erano rosita comunque
accetto
quattro mesi fa vengo contattato
all'editore di una piccola guida alla
recente al e che aveva usato dall'alto
ahimé viaggi per queste vittorie mi
contatterà dei complimentarsi con quanto
avevo scritto l'articolo precedente
dopo un breve scambio di mail questo
editore mi chiede se io le casse mi
trovasse in zona e con zona intendeva
kazakistan e se per caso avessi
intenzione di collaborare insieme a lui
aggiornare le sue guide io non mi
trovavo in zona abitano landa non avevo
intenzione di andarci ma rispondo sì
sarò lì a breve e si sono interessate a
collaborare
quindi tre mesi fa compie un biglietto
per il kazakistan
poco dopo parto e di questo lavoro non
ne viene fuori niente
l'aumento e stava andando in kazakistan
un contatto di un altare vista mi chiede
mi fa capire che c'era la possibilità di
pubblicare un articolo sul lago di aral
quindi arrivo almaty band 25 ore di
treno per andare sul lago di aral che
come vedete non è molto ospitale scolli
un giorno o due poi prendo 25 ore di
treno per tornare indietro e poi anche
di quello che non se ne fa niente
io jacquard in asia proseguo il mio
viaggio e quindi scendono bechis ton e
poi arrivò in tagikistan dal tagikistan
ento in kirghistan campo l'ultima tappa
del mio viaggio e in kirghistan di vento
alla guida di un gruppo di sette semi
sconosciuti che avevano risposto a un
annuncio sulla mia pagina facebook e
hanno deciso di venire questi sono loro
che sta si sono hanno scoperto di dover
camminare 1300 metri di dislivello e
l'hanno scoperto perché non lo sapevo
neanche io quindi due settimane fa 2
stima fasano in kirghistan una settimana
fa sono ansie da ma cominciare un master
in studi letterari e oggi sono qui al
ted a eboli ora chi sente questa storia
di solito tende a pensare che adesso
come mettere avere esperienza di
specifiche diverse debba necessariamente
avete idea chiara di quello che vuole
dalla vita o almeno della direzione da
tende forse qualcuno avrà capito che non
è così e se mi avesse chiesto sei mesi
fa
cosa sarebbe successo fino ad oggi io
non sarei stato in grado di rispondere
su nessuna delle cose vi ho raccontato
questo però non è un caso questo succede
perché io da più o meno dieci anni
investito molte energie nel cercare di
costruire uno stile di vita che mi
permettesse di fare scelte sbagliate o
nel migliore dei casi di non ce le ha
fatto e io quello di cui vi vorrei far
parlare oggi è appunto di libera scelta
e di come questo influenzi il modo in
cui vediamo noi stessi la nostra
identità in adolescenza primari papi e
soffrivo un po l'idea che la mia
identità fosse il 28 di tutto quello che
la società incongruo mi aveva dato in
pasto
mi sembrava di non essermi costruito da
solo
da una parte mi rendevo conto che la mia
generazione ha più opportunità di
chiunque altro in passato dall'altra
parte non riuscivo a capire come mai le
vite che vedevo evolversi attorno a me
fossero tutti così semplici
a me in qualche modo avevo paura che se
avesse seguito questo percorso comune mi
sarebbe essere qualcosa mi sembrava un
modo pigro di vivere oggi credo di
essere stato invitato qui per questo
motivo io nella mia vita lavoro 12 13
anni non ho mai passato un giorno
imbottigliato nel traffico o invece
disposto a questo dubbio esistenziale
che penso tutte abbiano avuto un punto
nell'alto della loro vita partendo per
un viaggio molto lungo
nel 2010 e gennaio 2010 compie un
biglietto dell'australia con l'idea di
partire da una pagina bianca il mio
obiettivo più grande nella vita è
appunto arrivare e non sapere cosa dove
vai a vedere scontrarmi con i miei
limiti per conoscere me stesso quindi ho
fatto senza un telefono senza un
computer senza un posto dove dormire la
prima sera con l'idea di danni sei mesi
per vedere dove sarei arrivato che
conosce sia le mie potenzialità ma anche
i miei i miei limiti
quel viaggio di sei mesi e 45 anni sono
tornato a casa della prima volta dopo
cinque anni ma comunque oggi ne sono
passati 10 ancora va avanti
dopo aver vissuto un anno in australia
due anni nuova zelanda decide di fare il
passo più lungo della gamba e cerca di
tornare in europa senza prendere aerei
attraversando l'asia quindi prendo un
volo per il timor est e dall inizio un
viaggio che anche lì dove va dai 6 mesi
ai guidato due anni durante questo
viaggio incontro tante persone le mie
idee iniziano a cambiare su quello che
volevo sui miei obiettivi della vita
inizia sentito la narrativa e si ripete
la storia sempre simili riflessione con
vita completamente diverse di quelle che
io avevo visto a casa mia
e infatti le storie come la mia ce ne
sono tantissime
sei andato su internet ne trovate quante
ne volete di gente che parte non solo
della nostra via per tantissimi tempo ci
sono anche delle the talk riguarda me
piacerebbe essere qui a dirvi che la mia
vita è migliore della vostra che la
strada alternativa è un'idea giusta da
tutti però non è proprio così
questa narrativa del mollare tutte parti
e del prende coraggio e tende
responsabilità della propria vita non è
non è sempre dipende sempre da una
scelta per me chiaramente questo è stato
benefico e se tornasse indietro io farei
tutto da capo
la realtà è che in dieci anni trascorsi
da europa asia e oceania
mi sono accorto che la via alternativa
non è poi così alternativa ci sono due
cose in particolare che ho notato la
prima è che chi basta è bene o che basta
meglio perché questo è l'obiettivo di
che parte del viaggio lungo termine è
quasi sempre chi già sta molto bene
la seconda cosa è che quando arriviamo
quando partiamo ed agiamo del mese in
mese in mese finiamo tutti per fare la
stessa cosa vi faccio un esempio questo
posto
io non sarei in grado di b b dove non
saprebbe vallo
questo è un asse centrale sulla montagna
a 2.000 metri di altezza e questo
simboleggiava un po il picco della mia
idea di libertà è arrivato in un posto
compressione avevo appena conosciuto che
potevo chiamare mio perché non c'è
neanche un sentiero ad arrivarci
questa foto in qualche modo il madman
tato un simbolo al tempo di questa mia
ricerca della libertà
finché non sono due nato a casa e ho
scoperto questo account instagram che si
chiama installare p e come vedete
raccoglie tutte queste raccoglie la
ripetizione costante di immagini che noi
chiediamo uniche modalità fanno parte di
un immaginario collettivo che non è poi
così alternativo qui c'è qualche altro
esempio
facciamo tutti le stesse cose non so
bene quale sia il messaggio raccogliere
da queste immagini però la nostra idea
di libera scelta e forse anche di
meritocrazia va un po i rivalutata
secondo me non esiste nessuna pagina
bianca da cui cominciare subiamo sempre
delle influenze esterne che ci spingono
in direzioni simili e questo non è un
problema perché poi le emozioni
personali quando uno finisce in uno di
questi posti hanno lo stesso valore non
cano il valore non cambia ecco e dove
quando ci identifichiamo nelle nostre
scelte e soprattutto ai nostri successi
senza tenere conto del privilegio o
dell'influenza che ci ha portato fino a
quel raggio
io sono cresciuto abbastanza con il mito
dell'uomo che si fa da sé e ho sempre
ammirato le persone che sacrificano
tutto oggi oggi abbiamo sentito tante
storie di successo di persone che
raggiungono obiettivi elevati con quelle
che pensavo fosse delle proprie forze
mi sono accorto col tempo che io non
sono quello che faccio e che punta
dritto verso un punto di arrivo non solo
appiattiva la mia vita ma poteva essere
causa di frustrazione il rancore
io in viaggio ho incontrato tante tante
persone impegnate le imprese notevoli
c'è chi pagine del mondo in bicicletta
che faremo da pieri e chi scava montagne
che colleziona montagna e trova la
propria dimensione in queste in queste
vette anch'io nel mio piccolo speravo di
trovare la mia dimensione in questo
lungo viaggio attraverso l'asia è però
un certo punto mi sono resa conto mette
a queste esperienze che qualcuno può
considerare estreme che poi magari tanto
estreme non lo sono e chi cerca magari
la propria identità nella carriera o in
un percorso comunque tradizionale non
c'è così tanta differenza
il problema principale identificarsi nei
propri successi è che tutto quello che
si mette in mezzo da noi è il punto
d'arrivo diventa un ostacolo incluse le
flessione che tu il motivo e nell'altro
si muovono a ritmi diversi che vanno più
piano rimangono indietro
io non sono quello che faccio piuttosto
ho notato che io sono le storie che
racconto le storie più belle però sono
quelle che io non ho mai pianificato un
anticipo mi sono sempre successe del
caso negli anni e per questo io ho
tentato di costruire uno stile di vita
che mi permettesse che permettesse agli
interisti li accadere
ho cercato di fare un piano di vita da
una vita senza piani o ridotto nel nella
teatro ridotto i miei possedimenti al
minimo io non ho la casa mia non ho la
macchina una bolletta dei bit rate o
scostato mio lavoro su internet non sono
legato a un posto fisico se una
posizionata una qualità sia te io mi
muovo senza nessun problema
come oggi qui continua viaggia è
abbastanza spesso ma anche viaggiano li
pianifico io vado un po a caso e tendo
sempre a tornare negli stessi posti
adesso non ho più l'interesse
riattaccare bandierina lo zaino il mio
quindi qui non è un invito a partire
perché non è che tutti non tutti possono
farlo e questo va riconosciuto è vero
sia chiaro piuttosto un invito a
cogliere il nuovo fare meno affidamento
a piano il lungo termine che vi spingono
a vivere col pilota automatico
nel mio caso ci sono stati dei risultati
tangibili
ad esempio io mi arrabbio molto poco
piccoli ostacoli che mi si mettono di
fronte ma anche mi sveglio la mattina
non senso di responsabilità che è molto
più elevato di come lo era in passato le
decisioni devo prende ogni giorno perché
non so quello che potrebbe accadere
e questo da una due fondi dalla mia vita
che prima non avevo
il motivo per cui sono qui a raccontarvi
questa storia però non è perché lo
dobbiamo fare anche voi è perché secondo
me ci siamo identificati troppo nel
punto di arrivo e quindi si è andata
peggio un senso di vicinanza per chi
commette errori e per chi magari per
qualche motivo non riesce a giocare allo
stesso gioco che siamo ritrovati a
giocare io vi invito quindi invece di
viaggiare al rendervi vulnerabili
abbandonando questa necessità della
scelta giusta a tutti i costi
e uscire da questo affanno del diventare
provocando un empatia che spesso è più
utile del consiglio di da guardo grazie
[Applauso]